Jeff Snyder here with director Tom
Harper the director of the arrow knots
and Wild Rose which if you've you know
been watching Collider all year you've
definitely heard me talk about at some
point on the air we will save some
questions about Wild Rose for the very
end of this cuz I got a geek out but we
we have to talk about the aeronauts cuz
this is a movie that's about to come out
and I feel like it's being overlooked
almost with it you know in with awards
season like this is a really great
old-fashioned adventure movie with two
really strong leads and maybe even
Felicity Jones is like most charming
performance that I've seen her give I
thought you did an incredible job so
congratulations thanks Jeff thank you
and how how did you first get involved
with this project well you know how long
ago did you sign on and all that it's
actually come from from inception to
screen remarkably quickly or quicker
than I've ever worked on anything before
cuz usually take such a long gestation
period there's a labor of love but I was
actually I was in Russia with my
cinematographer and we were shooting
warm piece and he'd heard a snippet of
this balloon flight in 1862 that was in
a book that's about to be published read
out on the radio and he said wouldn't it
be an amazing thing to make a movie all
sit in the sky
what visual opportunities that could
provide and so that was the starting
point and I'm gonna read about the
flight and a whole bunch of other
flights and some of the extraordinary
things that happened at the time and and
in this book I guess everything in the
film or 90% of what happens in the film
actually happened for real but not all
at the same time yeah it's like
everything that goes wrong feels like it
does yeah exactly and it becomes a
really impressive incredible story of
survival so you know what's it like
shooting within the confines of a hot
air balloon had you ever been up in a
hot air balloon before you made this
movie yeah I had actually on my dad's
60th birthday and I loved it actually
but that but this is actually a gas
balloon so this is this is because it's
a 19th century it's like I guess it's
like a birthday balloon it's full of gas
lighter than air and it takes you up and
I've never been in the gas balloon
before but they they really are
wonderful things and I suppose the one
that was one of the starting points for
was when we realized we're gonna make
the film is or can we build a 19th
century gas balloon and it turns out we
could and can we put our cast in it and
we could and so we did it you know a
real fair chunk of the film for real
with our cast in the basket 3,000 feet
above above London it was wild I mean
did Felicity or you or Eddie do they
have any fear of heights no I mean they
were fearless I had to say they went did
more than I ever thought that they would
or indeed I would do and I have immense
admiration for them you know so Felicity
did almost all of her own stunts and she
actually really put her through herself
through it was one of her you know right
from the very beginning she was adamant
that you know - she wanted her
performers to be as physical as possible
and therefore to embrace as much of the
physical action as possible and she
really did she started training six
months beforehand she really went to
extreme lengths and I think you can
really see that in her performance
absolutely I mean and I feel like a lot
of you know these kinds of movies to be
frank you know features the man saving
the woman and this is this kind of turns
the tables where she is sort of made to
be the hero like you know can you talk
about that choice yeah I mean it didn't
it wasn't like an active thought at the
beginning we're gonna make oh we're
gonna make the woman the hero in this it
just came from a point of what this that
the flight that it's primarily based on
where they went to 36,000 feet which is
higher than anyone's been before or
since in a balloon without additional
oxygen was a remarkable remarkable
flight just because of how high they
went but James glacier and the pilot he
was with Henry Cox well they didn't
really speak in the in on that flight
because they were so busy taking
measurements and wasp before they
achieved was remarkable two people in a
basket not talking to each other doesn't
necessarily make for the most
interesting movie sure so we look to
other characters and to other balloon
flights to see for inspiration and there
was this woman Sophie Blanchard who
lived 40 years previously and she was a
kind of a firecracker of a woman who was
flamboyant and did acrobatics and was
said of fireworks from her basket and
she became Napoleon's head of
Aeronautics at of ballooning and every
time he had a military possession she'd
be there with us
on the balloon and so and actually
tragically fell to her death when she
set up a firework into her balloon which
exploded over the Paris skyline so so
anyway but she was this very sort of
markedly different character from the
meticulous James glacier and so we
thought well if you put those two in a
balloon together and it's a confined
space of the basket that's gonna provide
some Sparks and then just naturally as
because he was the scientist and she was
the pilot and because she was the more
physical more flamboyant and the more
instinctive person and it seemed natural
that she would be the person to to do
the most the action and is indeed the
person that goes to the extreme links at
the top of the atmosphere sure I see so
it's not like it's a true story per se
but - truce - truce Tory's kind of
melded together in a sense yeah I mean a
draws from a number of true stories I
guess it sort of inspired by a bunch of
the flights that actually did happen so
how do you keep things visually
interesting though within such a small
space because like I imagine that's one
of the challenges yeah I'm Paul I mean
actually that is one of the things
really appealed to me about the film
because so much of it is actually just
two people in a confined space but of
course the whole world is changing with
them as they go around and then they
experience all sorts of things from a
storm to going through clouds to you
know to kind of fighting for survival as
they plummet to earth at the end but so
we just thought very carefully about how
each let that progression that visual
progression I suppose as they go up
through the atmosphere and how the
layers change and how the Sun changes
and obviously the Sun the Sun setting
and so actually it's almost like each
level of the atmosphere is a different
world right it's it was it seemed like a
great opportunity to play with light
yeah cinematographer honest I forgive me
it's my friend and frequent collaborator
guy cultural steel we do peaky blinders
together which where we met and we then
since did warm piece Wild Rose so we've
worked together a bunch yeah I just
thought the the look of the summit was
very majestic thanks yeah yeah I mean
also we really wanted it to feel modern
in the basket as well so the there are
some flashbacks in the mood
they're also on anamorphic lenses
they're much more period and feel much
more static camera but everything in
that basket is really we wanted to feel
like a modern film and I've always that
was all the thing that always strikes me
about when I work on period dramas is
actually you know with just the same you
know pin think that the the the setting
has changed and there are many things
that have sort of material things have
changed but the fundamental human
emotions are exactly the same pretty
much and so it's about accessing that as
closely as possible I like that Eddie
you know it was kind of like all
business and and Felicity was a bit of a
showman and there's a scene early where
she's kind of showing off for the crowd
that involves the dog yeah does the
audience like what is the reaction to
that moment because I felt like I gasped
I saw was great seeing it with an autism
that they're doing is to always like
leap up by that much another thing that
actually happened
we need to spoil it a spoilers but yeah
they they throw at the basket I mean but
the dog has dogs fine oh my god I see it
was a stunt dog it wasn't a real throw
the real dog at the basket that would
have been not good right so this stunt
dog was used to getting thrown around he
was like a very expensive stuffed dog
not nice or stuffed dog I don't know
imagine if they were actual like stunt
dogs yeah do you feel any increased
pressure since this is sort of the
reunion of these two actors who are in
this like you know well reviewed movie
we did like was was this actively seen
as like a reunion when you guys are
working together shooting it yeah I mean
I guess sir I mean what you know it's it
is reunion I guess so of sorts but um
but it was never a pressure I don't
think I mean how it is that you're asked
at the time it wasn't it was just a
pleasure because because they they got
on so well and they had such a great
chemistry and rapport together and and
actually it was a sort of a great sort
of starting bedrock to start them to
making the movie and I mean if it didn't
get on two people in a confined space
for 90 minutes would have been would
have been challenging so I gotta ask you
the tough questions yours yeah good
and so when Amazon comes to you and says
you know we've decided to switch our
strategy a little bit yes film a
two-week real release before it comes to
prime in time for the holidays or
everybody will be able to watch it you
know with their families over the
holidays but it means at the IMAX
release that you'd planned for is sort
of out the window like what's your
reaction to this is it frustrating do
you understand the emphasis on streaming
like where are you coming from in all of
this
there's a combination of all sort of
things really in truth it's you know it
was designed to be shown on the big
screen it is a spectacle it is a big
screen experience and so I want as many
people to see on the big screen as
possible we do live in a changing times
a rapidly changing times and there are
you know four original films people go
out and see original films in a cinema
is harder to get those audiences and and
what Amazon and Netflix and the
streamers are providing in terms of you
know this is as an original film there's
not based on our IP that is reasonably
expensive is we wouldn't have got made
really anywhere else and I'm very
grateful that we got the chance to make
this movie and that is a great thing and
if it it wouldn't necessarily be made if
if it weren't if it weren't for the
streamers so you know I'm sorry that it
doesn't get a longer release I would
like I hope that people make the choice
to go and see on the big screen at the
same time as I'm pleased that loads of
people are gonna millions of people
worldwide will get to watch it over
Christmas on Amazon Prime so you know
it's just um it's a factor of the
changing world and you have to roll with
it and embrace the opportunities that
that provides and if that means that
they're gonna give us the money to make
films like aeronauts then that's a good
thing right
I mean I want to ask about that like as
a storyteller like what do you make of
the current streaming wars like and this
and this hunger for content isn't is now
a better time than ever to be a creator
and a censor yeah I think so I mean this
is it's harder to get your work noticed
I think because there is so much good
material out there but that sort of
provokes you and challenges you to think
harder about what you do and to in a
drive for excellence as well you know
you know you're looking for things that
really cut through that will really
capture people's imagination so yeah I
think I think there's so much great
great material out there and
and even you know and and films as well
you know with with with the with the
combination of the big IP and the big
franchises and then all everything that
the stream is making the more original
low budget stuff it feels like it's very
rich rich spectrum so this is your
second film this year and I know that
Wild Rose was shot a while ago and the
release got held up a little bit but
like I feel like this is like your
Spielberg moment or Clint Eastwood
moment were two big movies to two really
good movies in the same year has it
opened more doors for you in the
industry taken more meetings and stuff
off these movies well we just finish
this like only a few weeks ago so Wow
seven weeks ago and I've been running
around with it going to festivals and
stuff so I haven't really stopped to
think and and actually what I really
looking forward to is just taking a step
back and watching some other movies and
recharging the creative batteries and
just going to some museums and reading
some books and you know that kind of
thing what kind of stuff do you like to
read I'm curious because I think reading
is a lost art these days like no I don't
know a lot of people who go home and
just read for pleasure and it's sad to
me I love books what are you reading I
actually read like the stuff I read for
pleasure is sort of almost stuff that
can't be work if you know what I mean so
I tend to read like essays I've been
reading in praise of shadows which is a
sort of an essay on Japanese aesthetics
okay I've been reading meets their own a
book about trees but you know quite
random things that cannot be
work-related and because I think that
you know so much of my life is dominated
by filmmaking just find spaces where you
can just philosophy or or or nature or
aesthetics or you know whatever it is
just to stretch the other parts of your
brain in your imagination I think is
really useful that's interesting to me
people ask you know I have a lot of
friends obviously in this movie space
they're always while you listen my
podcast and like I don't want to listen
to podcast talk enough about movies so
Wildrose
you know was absolutely terrific you'd
work with Jesse Buckley before on worn
piece right yes what what made you think
that she was right to play this
character Rosalyn was Jesse Jesse is a
very formidable personality and she
she's someone that I found very
inspiring and loved working with on one
piece and we were looking for something
to work on together so she was in the
forefront of my mind and then and then
this script came along that I was
actually sort of gearing up to make
Aaron and I was taking a bit longer than
I expected to come together and then
this script sort of turns up and and
within the two pages of reading it it
was you know it was a voice that could
only be Jesse's coming from screaming
out the page at me and fortunately she
thought the same thing and it was a it
was it's very rare you get or I in my
experience that I've had like no brain
as where it's like yes I want to make
this film I know exactly who should play
it isn't usually much more grave than
that and you well I should I should and
I'm not sure you try and convince
yourself and you convince yourself out
of it whereas this is one that was just
right from the very beginning it's like
I want to make this film and I will got
to get took the Jesse can you like the
reaction to that movie I think has been
through the roof and it sends you out of
the theater with chills as she sings the
Sun Glasgow which I think I mean is neon
giving that an awards push this year in
the Best Original Song category do you
know yeah I mean I think so it's a you
know it's a smaller movie and it's a
it's it's something that people have
discovered over time so I don't think it
has the kind of the big surge of the
other big awards contenders so but I I
hope that people will find it and it
seems them more and more people are
gonna find it and it is an amazing story
behind that song because it's written of
course by Mary Steenburgen yeah the
actress the brilliant actress and
actually brilliant songwriter because
she she had a there was an article as
well it recently just read it see when
she had the sort of routine surgery and
for I think was an elbow operation or
something anyway but she went under
general anaesthetic and when she woke up
she could hear music and it sort of
changed her life and and and she started
writing songs she couldn't do anything
but kind of get the music out and when
we were looking for a song for the end
of the movie we couldn't find it and we
were starting to freak out because it's
a really as you know a key
part of the movie right I saw like I
think in that art that same article it's
at the end of the scripture says you
know she sings a incredible song and in
the end it was like that's easier said
than done yeah exactly we couldn't find
anything but I think because Mary is an
actress and she read the script and got
inside the mind of the character she was
able to to catch the emotion of the
moment
have you heard from singers who have
seen that film and been inspired I have
I don't know that I have Ashley how did
you get your start in this business I
show films I made a lot short films
along not very good short films and
slowly I got better over time I think
and then I made one called Cubs that
sort of captured the zeitgeist for
whatever reason and that you know that
I'd made the film just before that that
that I'd spent a long time trying to
raise the money for and we shot it and
yeah I actually thought it was pretty
good we send it to festivals worldwide
and it didn't get it I actually gone to
one obscure German poetry festival and
that was it and then I was all ready to
give up and I was feeling very
despondent and Cubs came together and I
thought well I'll do this and if this
doesn't work then that's you know that's
it and then for whatever reason that
went everywhere and it was I think it
was a better film but I don't know that
it was that much better than the
previous one but it was just hit that
vein and so that guy you like signed in
everything and yeah I mean it was a slow
process it was that and then another the
next year the Cubs enabled me to make
another short film and then I made some
short documentaries and slowly but
surely you know it gathered momentum and
and do you prefer I mean what's the
difference that the biggest difference
for you as a director in terms of
working in film and television because
like you said you've done episodes of
peaky blinders and some other really
cool stuff it's um
there are there's there some differences
in sort of logistics and it's also just
about the thinking about the big screen
and kind of a what's gonna get people to
go into Wow
it's all changing of course I yeah it's
about it's about that I suppose it's
about the scope and it's about the time
that you have and it's about really
thinking about the kind of scale of what
you're telling but often it's not very
often it can be not very different and I
think they're coming kind of coming
closer and closer up but but certainly
with something like aranaut sand Wild
Rose you know is in the forefront of
your mind
as you know things that aren't based on
big-ip or there are no Fred Jones it's
like what is what is it that's gonna
make people come into a cinema and pay
the money and see it sit through it and
you know for for the air annoyance it's
the spectacle it's the real-time quality
it's the the the big sequences that that
hopefully demand to be seen on a big
screen and that will be what gets people
in those two weeks before it comes out
at Amazon Prime and I think that for a
while Rose it's the it's nice the music
and it's there but it's also this I
think it's the singularity of the
storytelling as well I think it's you
know like the compact perspective of you
know one one journey usually but of
course there's a million exceptions to
any rule so so what's next for you what
are you what are you working on they're
developing I mean I've got number of
things bubbling in the fires in fires
again like I'm not quite sure I can't
want to take a B to recharge but I do
have a project called of judgment in
Moscow that's based on any more tools
he's booked I'm working on with Ken
Branagh and so maybe that'll be the
thing that pops up first okay are you
still attached to do that
the working title thing I lost for words
no more I see no that's that was a fun
thing that we worked in a while you
never trust those things alright listen
thank you so much for coming in when
when can folks see the aeronaut both in
theaters and on Amazon Prime video
December the 6th in the cinema so I hope
as many people as possible guys you
really get out on the big screen really
it deserves to be seen up there it's
it's beautiful and then two weeks they
said to send the 20th in time for
Christmas all right perfect
well thank you so much for not see
thanks for watching polite or calm guys